[Music]
you look fantastic you have uh you've
lost a
you've lost some weight around two
ounces um
[Laughter]
i was gonna say about two ounces yeah um
no i stopped drinking and i just kind of
put the weight off really so you you
stop drinking and the weight just
because they say that's yeah that can
really make a huge difference yeah i was
having uh you know
a lot of vodka with sausage and uh
was the sausage in the drink yeah oh wow
delicious yeah but bad for you bad for
you uh swizzle sausage yeah i was
getting in too much trouble with the
drink and stuff so i just kind of was
there an incident that sort of uh
because everyone when they if they stop
drinking there's usually one thing that
happens that makes them think okay now i
gotta
cut back this was about 20 things um
one night i was walking
that's it that's the story
you just were like i've got to stop
walking this walking thing is terrible
um i i i was walking through new york
and i was
walking over out towards one of the
bridges to walk home and
i was in the lower east side and i had
gotten into the whiskey that night and i
was listening to my headphones and
this guy in a jag jaguar jaguar war how
do you say it jaguar yeah one of those
cut me off when i was
crossing ludlow street yeah
now if it had been a chevy lumina i
wouldn't have cared right
but this is a jag and some fancy
[ __ ] in there and uh
yeah
and um
so as he cut me off i hit the car as
hard as i can with my hands just like
bam
hey i was saying hi man zach you're real
cool yeah and
i had some whiskey i got my headphones
on i just hit a jaguar yeah
and i you know i just keep walking and
tap on my shoulder about 20 seconds
later
and i turn around and it's
two
six foot six guys
12 by 12. and
they were cubes they were cute but
anyway there were two
huge six foot six guys and i turn around
i take my headphones off
and they
they both
at the same time spit my face
you're kidding and i don't know if
you've ever been spitting your face
non-sexually
but
[Laughter]
all i remember is
being so stunned and they walked away i
didn't really even say anything because
i didn't know what to say
and i remember
reaching into a trash can and grabbing a
beer bottle and yeah and saying to
myself out loud
nobody spits in zach galifianakis's face
i threw the beer bottle at the car
and it missed
and that's my story yeah i wish you had
said
nothing big happened but that's one of
the reasons i
you decided to cut back yeah cut back
did the guys the guys didn't recognize
they spit on you they obviously didn't
recognize you what about me now i was
wearing a nixon mask
well this story is changing a lot no i
don't think no they didn't recognize no
if they did recognize me they probably
would have done more than spit my face
yeah but i'm curious do you like uh you
know
we've known you for a really long time
and we've seen you blow up and become
this big star do you like being famous
and being recognized
uh i don't and i understand the irony of
saying that on a talk show um
but i i don't i don't i haven't i've had
trouble i'm kind of private and i try to
if i see a pack of teenagers walking my
way forget it i will run right yeah
you'll run the other way yeah run the
other way for sure yeah it's it's it's a
tricky thing
to be noticed do you notice that there's
a kind of like is a certain kind of
person that notices you more than well
there's never anybody wearing a dr smock
it's always somebody like with a
who-farted
t-shirt never a surgeon never a surgeon